hey guys it's justine and this is going
to be a really fun video
this is going to be a holiday gift guide
that i'm doing with best buy so thank
you so much best buy for sponsoring this
video
if you guys have been following along
over the past couple of months i
partnered with them to showcase some
really fun products over on instagram we
even did a really cool live stream so
thank you to everyone who was able to
tune in for that but today i'm gonna
kind of take all of the products that
i've been talking about
and put them all in one single video and
a lot of things that i'm showing you
i've actually
already got as gifts for friends i'm not
going to say who
so if any of my friends are watching
this there's a really good chance that a
lot of the things that i'm showing you
it's on the way this year is so
different than
previous years but what's great about
best buy is they have basically been
there for me over the past couple of
months when i've needed things same day
now i can just order things online and
they have curbside pickup so i basically
don't even have to leave my car
i pick the things that i want i drive
there
and they bring it to me it's incredible
you order something online you can roll
up
check in and they will bring you your
package and shop safe and
fun so the things that i want to start
with are these these are the philips hue
lights now i've talked about these in so
many different videos i basically have
my entire house hooked up to these all
of my lights in my ceilings in my lamps
they have so many different models and
various kinds they have injury of
outdoor you can connect them with any of
your smart home devices
and you're able to control it with your
voice so these you can change the colors
but there's also two new ones that just
recently came out
these are the filament bulbs so these
kind of give off
a really warm amber hue actually using
it in this light right behind me
so you're getting this cool retro look
but you can control this with your phone
so you guys can see this is my hue app i
have everything all listed and labeled
so right now we're going to go into my
office
and this big lamp in the back watch this
i can change the colors
so since this filament bulb is not one
of the colored bulbs you can't change
this color but you can change
the brightness so you turn it all the
way up or
all the way down we'll keep it all the
way up if you are looking to get these
for somebody i would
definitely find out if they have them
already because if they do
then they most likely have a starter kit
with the starter kit that will allow you
to connect all of these bulbs to your
router
obviously health and wellness is a huge
focus i think for a lot of people this
year
as it has been in the past but this year
specifically taking care of your health
and bringing that into your own hands is
something that's very important so
these have been two of the things that i
absolutely love this is a little
thermometer that actually uses infrared
so you can just take your temperature
just like this that data will be
recorded and sent to your phone the one
thing that i have found that is the most
important thing
is knowing what your normal is so being
able to take that every single day
you'll be able to see the trends you'll
be able to spot the differences
and know when something is up this is
also something else that i absolutely
love this is the bpm
connect i've been using this several
times a week i don't do this every
single day this is a blood pressure
monitor
so this also will connect to an app on
your phone so you're able to keep all of
that data and all of those records
this could also be a great gift for
older family members or even anybody who
might have health concerns
when it comes to blood pressure all of
the data is tracked in an app
and you can easily share it if you need
to send it to a doctor and being able to
do
these simple tasks at home could
potentially be life-saving
so definitely highly recommend these
again all of the stuff that we're
talking about you can find on
bestbuy.com and i will put links in the
description to each of the products that
i talked about so you can find out more
about them
also in the health and wellness
department is this
this is the home soap
so what this is it's a uv sanitizer and
it's big enough
that you're able to put all kinds of
larger devices
like tablets multiple phones if i want
to put
my blood pressure monitor in there close
it up
wait 10 minutes and then my item has
been sanitized
yeah i know it's incredible
this next item is the ninja coffee maker
and i never knew
until recently that ninja made coffee
makers and this one is a kitchenaid
coffee and spice grinder i've been such
a huge fan of ninja brand
products for a very long time so sister
jenna recently said that she was looking
for a coffee maker and i was like
okay guess what i've got you covered so
i did the initial unboxing and first
test of it just to make sure that it was
justine approved
and it was and this thing is really
really cool because it also has a milk
frother
[Music]
next up is this insignia mini retro
fridge when i saw this i was like this
is
what my office has been missing this is
my office
i edit right next to this refrigerator i
do my live streaming
right across from it i don't even have
to leave this room
when i want a frozen peanut butter and
jelly sandwich i have a mini fridge
and a mini freezer in my office this is
the best thing ever
so this refrigerator is by insignia it
comes in a bunch of different colors
and kind of has this real vintage look
as well this is great for anybody that's
maybe in a dorm
or even if you're at a work from home
situation like me
it's perfect for small spaces and i
cannot tell you this freezer
is actually really cold so since my
refrigerator
freezer has made me a little chilly this
next thing is actually for my vehicle i
got this because we've been doing a lot
of road trips recently
and we went to the mountains and it was
very very cold and i was getting some
really cool time-lapse shots
so this is a heated blanket that can
plug right into your car
this was so cozy in the back of my car
when i was freezing just waiting for my
video to be done i feel like this is a
really fun gift for anybody as like an
emergency blanket just to have them keep
in their car
but also if you're doing any road trips
this holiday season
keep yourself warm or if you have a
passenger who tends to disagree with you
on the temperature you can just throw
this at them and save here now you're
warm
this next product i can't even tell you
how this has honestly changed my life
i never ever thought that i would be the
person
to have a garden and now 2020 justine
has a garden this is the aerogarden and
what's amazing about this is
you get these little seed pods and you
put them inside of the aerogarden
you put water they give you a timer so
every two weeks you're supposed to
put some plant food in i have got
so much joy out of watching these plants
grow
can you just can we just look at this
this is so
amazing like this has been the most
exciting thing like every single day i
come down here and this has grown a
little bit more
i trim it i prune i harvest
i'm a farmer now i'm i'm farming
i need to get another one of these i
need to get a bigger one i want to start
growing lettuce
maybe even tomatoes i don't even like
tomatoes but i want to grow them and eat
them because why
i would know that i grew them myself
this is the basil
i've got two types of basil i have mint
the thyme
it's uh it's having a struggle it's
taken its time i'm just so upset that it
took me this long to get one like i wish
that i
would have got this back in march
because i had started cooking a lot more
since i've been spending more time at
home
and to be able to sort of just wake up
every day look at my plants
see how they're doing and i spend a lot
of time pruning them now
i mean this basil is getting out of
control like the amount of
harvest that i'm getting on a daily
basis it's gonna be more than i can even
handle myself
it's really cool because i've been able
to give my sister some fresh herbs as
well
and there's all kinds of different seed
pods i did the gourmet herbs one
as my first test lettuce 2021 it is on
the horizon
something that i've also really loved is
the oculus quest ii now this has been
really great because i feel like for
many of us obviously we can't go
anywhere anymore
so to be able to kind of have the quest
kind of
take me out of my indoor element and i
can basically go wherever i want
i also was really enjoying the oculus
quest just watching like youtube videos
so it's kind of fun because you can go
into like a little theater mode and just
watch content and it kind of almost
makes you feel like you're at a movie
theater
have some popcorn you're set to go this
last one is a very simple gift this is
the jbl clip
i have loved the jbl clip i used to take
this thing
on hikes this thing traveled with me
around the world i'm able to clip it
onto my backpack it connects to
bluetooth
so you're easily able to play music
through it like this is also a really
great stocking stuffer i don't know
if you guys and your family have
stockings
my family we do we still have stockings
and it's so crazy because my mom
she will manage to fit so much stuff
in these stockings that will come down
on christmas day
and they are just like basically hanging
down all the way to the ground i'm like
mom
how could you possibly fit any more in
there so if you are a family that has
stockings
here you go jbl clip well thank you guys
so much for watching
this was a really fun video to kind of
put together and show you kind of a wide
array of gifs that you can find on
bestbuy.com and i've said this before
like at best buy it's kind of a
misconception because you just think
of tvs or laptops most of the time but
you can basically get anything they have
so many fun
really cool unique gifts of course yes
they do have all of the tech as well
that's why it's so incredible because
they have
so many different things no doubt about
it you can find something for anyone on
your list this year
and here's another hot tip you can just
buy it and mail it to their house
that's what i'm doing this year if i'm
not doing curbside pickup check your
mail friends
i would love to know from you guys what
is the one thing that is on your holiday
wish list this year
i'll be reading those and i will see you
guys in my next video bye